agora
todos pra mim é um prazer estar aqui
hoje com vocês para compartilhar minhas
experiências e eu vou contar para vocês
em forma de história toda toda a
experiência que eu vou compartilhar hoje
e ela começa quando eu tinha entre três
e sete anos de idade quando eu morava no
interior de minas gerais
é na mesma rua que meus avós eu lembro
que aquele trajeto que tinham acho que
cerca de 300 metros para mim parece 33
quilômetros e era naquele momento em que
eu ia da minha casa até a casa dos meus
avós caminhando com meu pai era muito
legal porque é um momento que eu tinha
um único com ele e de fazer diversas
perguntas das famosas fases do porquê e
do como que acho que todo mundo passa
por isso né perguntas do tipo por que o
avião voa porque ela é branca porque no
brasil era dia e no japão era noite
essas perguntas quando eu olho pra trás
eu vejo que foram fundamentais para que
eu pudesse conseguir expressar e formar
minhas opiniões sobre as mais diversas
coisas é que da minha vida até os dias
de hoje
e aí eu penso pensando refletindo sobre
isso eu vejo que se não tivesse tido a
sorte de de ter sido influenciado a
pensar de maneira diferente ea olhar as
mais diversas situações pelo olhar do
outro eu não teria feito o que eu
consegui fazer a minha trajetória
pessoal e profissional de vida e aí a
gente chega é quando eu decidi fazer
relações públicas hoje eu sou como
comunicador trabalho na na general
electric sólida de comunicação digital
na américa latina
amo o que faço adoro comunicação não
teria outra coisa se não fosse
comunicação mas a minha profissão me
permitiu ver o mundo de uma outra forma
completamente diferente daquela forma lá
de trás quando eu tinha dos 37 anos
fazia todas aquelas perguntas para o meu
pai olhando pra pra tudo isso eu vejo
que o primeiro é a discussão aqui não é
discutir se o melhor onde queijo é o
mineiro ou é o paulista ou se são paulo
é melhor que nós
tais não muito pelo contrário hoje eu tô
aqui pra gente conseguir é e convidar
vocês que a gente possa olhar e tirar
todos os nossos preconceitos das coisas
diversas que a gente tem que a gente
acha que sabe para formar novos
conceitos e idéias não é itu e isso eu
faço constantemente na minha vida então
uma dessas coisas e para que vocês
possam entender por que estou falando
tudo isso é eu nasci no final da década
de 80 e início da década de 90 ea gente
passava uma estabilidade econômica muito
grande no brasil é e eu tive uma vida
muito se engana
então eu de forma bem resumida eu nasci
em belo horizonte mas morei no rio de
janeiro
depois fui morar em pará de minas de
pará de minas eu vim morar em são paulo
de são paulo eu fui morar em santo
antônio do amparo santo dão amparo eu
fui morar em itaúna de itaúna eu voltei
para são paulo e foi aqui que eu decidi
fazer relações públicas e estudar
comunicação porque eram que eu realmente
amava fazer ea minha profissão me
permitiu por conta do meu interesse e
curiosidade e vontade de aprender e e
esforço em muitas vezes amor algumas
vezes fora do brasil
a primeira delas foi no canadá quando
foi estudar em 2007 é estudar inglês é
fazer um intercâmbio de línguas e depois
o ano passado em 2013 quando eu tive a
oportunidade de trabalhar em um congo
tudo isso parece simples mas todas essas
peças desse quebra cabeça eles só
fizeram sentido quando eu fui morar
quando eu fui passear em macau quando
estava morando em hong kong e macau fica
perto de qom onde cerca de uma hora de
lancha rápida você consegue fazer uma
viagem é de um dia e foi a primeira
colônia européia na ásia então os
portugueses quando chegar em macau eles
conseguiram explorar todas as riquezas
no período das grandes navegações por
pela porta de entrada de macau
e aí quando eu cheguei lá e vi aquela
arquitetura é daqueles lugares no centro
de macau que mais parecia com a cidade
do rio de janeiro do que com
a vizinha ronconi a os calçados calças o
calçamento os passeios né de macau tinha
aquelas pedrinhas portuguesas que mais
se assemelhavam com o calçadão carioca
do que com a cultura oriental asiática e
aí eu eu pensei mas como tudo isso se
encaixa no meio desse desse quebra
cabeça como seria o brasil se a gente
que não fosse colonizada por portugueses
é porque aquele era um retrato de que
uma colonização muda uma cultura e tem
influencia na forma de no seu
desenvolvimento e tudo mais
e aquelas placas e aqui eu tenho um
exemplo delas todas as uma das heranças
da cultura da colonização portuguesa foi
a língua marcar hoje não as pessoas não
falam português mas português é uma
língua oficial é na ilha então todas as
comunicações todas as placas
elas têm mandarim o cantonês que é um
outro idioma aqui do sudeste asiático
mas com tradução em português
pra mim sinceramente eu me sentia um
filme chinês com legenda em português
foi um dia foi um final de semana muito
maluco porque quando estava em rondon de
todas aquelas placas eu não consegui
entender saída exit ou qualquer coisa do
tipo o banheiro toalete restaurante
quando cheguei macau e eu vi que os
ideogramas é mandar em cantonês tinha um
sentido e que algumas vezes era tipo
igreja da sé eu falo igual não é tão não
é tão diferente assim quanto imaginava
mas o que tudo isso tem a ver com os
temas que a gente discute hoje né de
interdisciplinaridade globalização
localização e inovação
aí vou compartilhar com vocês três temas
o que eu acho que foi muito importante
nessa convivência que tive com outras
culturas
a primeira delas é quando quando você
está numa cultura que é totalmente
diferente da sua é fugir da sua zona de
conforto para vivenciar a experiência da
forma como acontece naquele lugar
isso é muito importante porque as
barreiras do ici o mais lá elas são
ela é algumas vezes nos impede de se
jogar 100% naquela cultura e ver como as
pessoas se expressam o como as pessoas
pensam realmente enxergar pelo olhar
delas somente dessa manhã ea outra coisa
que eu pergunto pra vocês é a gente e
voltando ao ponto dos preconceitos é
quem nunca se pegou pensando oh dizendo
do tipo a mais lá
no brasil eles não falam como fazendo
barulho a se eu tivesse com alguns
amigos meus aqui ela tem aquele lugar
esquece isso o meu convite é tente fazer
amizades e conhecer as pessoas daquele
lugar
somente dessa maneira eu consegui aqui a
gente tem duas fotos que expressa as
situações
eu consegui visitar as muralhas da china
com meus amigos chineses no ônibus em
que só eu era estrangeiro e todo mundo
falava chinesa era um ônibus local
público
imagina a gente pegando o ônibus pra mim
pra universidade federal do abc hoje da
praça da sé até aqui era um ônibus
normal mas se útil se eu não tivesse a
oportunidade tem meus amigos chineses
pra me guiar nessa aventura para mim era
uma aventura porque não consegui
entender o idioma eu não teria tido essa
experiência e outra ocasião dessa foto
em preto e branca foi quando estava em
honkong e meus amigos me chamaram pra
comer um ramen é uma comida japonesa
quando cheguei na porta do restaurante
eu falei igual ao que eu vou comer hoje
já tinha estivesse diversas coisas
diferente tipo por dia a coisa mais
diferente que eu comi com onde foi um
tanto o pudim que é um uma gelatina
feita de do mocotó do casco da tartaruga
para vocês entenderem o gosto parece
amoxil e parece uma gelatina preta então
eles chamam isso de doce
foi meu bolo de aniversário em maio
aí quando cheguei na porta do
restaurante inteligente que eu vou comer
hoje não entendi o cardápio não sabia
que as pessoas vão comer mas já falei
tudo bem vamos lá e aí eu falei gente
que com o score especial da casa só isso
aqui foi então tá bom comer mas no final
das contas foi muito interessante que eu
tive oportunidade de comer o tradicional
flamengo japonesa é um cara que você
tenha uma ideia é um pote onde você tem
um modelo é que o macarrão
mas junto com lucas você tem cara de
pouco você tem ovo e você tem algumas
algas né básico do prata isso mas é
muito gostoso tipo misto shiro muito
mais incrementado eu falei um acho que
isso acabou no brasil
mas tudo isso e essa atitude fizeram com
que eu pudesse conhecer e experimentar
sabores olhar a cultura do outro saindo
da minha zona de conforto
e o segundo foi o que eu aprendi também
sem dúvida ligado à zona de conforto é
prender que para você compartilhar ea
tentar ajudar o outro local o seu
trabalho na forma como você está se
comunicando no seu dia a dia e se
expressando você nem sempre o que
funciona aqui no brasil vai funcionar do
outro lado do mundo ou vai funcionar no
estado vizinho nosso a gente precisa
entender simplesmente que as diferenças
existem e que pra você fazer qualquer
tipo de comparação em qualquer tipo para
adicionar novas idéias você tem que
respeitar essa cultura local e não e não
a partir da premissa de que há é
diferente eles estão nós temos uma
cultura mais avançada ou a gente está no
momento mais adiantado não até porque
para fazer esse tipo de de de conceito a
gente precisa tomar nossa cultura como
referência e por quê porque a nossa
melhor do que a deles e vice versa
eu aprendi isso no meu dia a dia na ásia
e um exemplo básico disso é de um ponto
de atenção que a gente precisa ter nem
sempre a cultura é a mesma o fuso
horário é o mesmo
a forma como as pessoas relacionam é a
mesma
por exemplo aqui no brasil eu respeitar
as pessoas me perguntavam alguma coisa
meus amigos e eu respondi pra eles não
algumas vezes ficou fazendo assim com a
boca é essa que vocês fazem isso mas eu
fazia
é é quando cheguei na ásia e eu respondi
as pessoas três vezes fazendo as pessoas
me chamaram de campo e falar assim pedro
eu não sei se você sabe mas fazer aqui é
como se estivesse tratando a gente com
uma criança de 3 anos de idade
é eu recomendo que você faça isso falei
nossa
muito obrigado como falar porque eu não
sabia disso eu faço isso há 26 anos da
minha vida e pra mim é natural mais
brigado
se eu fizer de novo é em alerta porque
eu não quero fazer isso novamente é e
isso acontece muitas vezes no brasil por
exemplo uma pessoa do norte consegue se
comunicar com uma pessoa do sul e os
sotaques nem o seu jornalismo dão
sotaque na forma como ela se comunica
mas é mas não impede na forma de se
relacionar dentre essas pessoas não
acontecem entre países do mundo então
quando você pensa e você está numa
estrutura de trabalhar e se desenvolver
e eu acredito que a universidade federal
do abc
ela proporciona isso para as pessoas que
elas faculdade do século 21 literalmente
é a gente precisa ter esse tipo de
sensibilidade
quando vai se relacionar com pessoas que
são diferentes da sua cultura aqui junto
a gente possa transformar e trazer um
melhor meu do melhor dela e formar novas
idéias e o terceira coisa dessa
experiência foi com relação à distância
eu achei que a distância realmente seria
muito difícil na forma de me relacionar
com as pessoas realmente ela é porque
quando você está no dia a dia é com as
pessoas a convivência diária
obrigatoriamente ela te aproxima das
pessoas torna mais fácil tipo de a forma
de se relacionar é mas enfim eu aprendi
com essa menina trabalha com kong que se
você tem flexibilidade para escutar as
pessoas
sentar com ela sem entender a realidade
delas e junto conseguir construir uma
coisa verdadeira que faz sentido pra
você pra ela a chance de sucesso em seu
trabalho conselho gigantescas um exemplo
disso foi uma das comunidades virtuais
que a gente construiu é para três
regiões a gente tinha o nosso desafio
foi a gente em colocar uma comunidade
virtual onde a gente iria compartilhar
informações das 13 regiões da empresa em
que eu trabalho com informações básicas
institucionais é para que sejam eles
pudessem saber uma das outras e que o
acesso da informação fosse fácil no
princípio é como aprendizado a gente
fazia essas reuniões colocava todo mundo
num call um conference call e todo mundo
participava e quando a gente apresentar
o projeto as pessoas entendiam via
importância mas elas num não comprava a
idéia então como foi o aprendizado ea
gente precisou se reúne com os três
líderes comunicação de cada uma das
regiões
e junto com esses líderes de comunicação
entender qual é a necessidade dele qual
é o momento que estava passando como a
gente poderia ajudar ele desenvolveu um
material que a gente precisava porque
somente neste momento que a gente
conseguiu ouvir o outro e adaptar todas
essas necessidades que a gente conseguir
chegar a essa comunidade virtual dentro
do prazo e da maneira como a gente
esperava
então sim isso é fundamental e você deve
estar perguntando tá mas se falou tudo
isso eu já vi globalização em nova é a
localização mas é onde está a inovação
no meio disso tudo
a inovação eu acredito que ela não vem
de uma forma mega inovadora de pensar
onde a criança desde a criação de um
aplicativo super é transformador como
facebook mas é escutar e ouvir o outro
sentar com ele entender que no diálogo
na escuta na compreensão que a gente
juntos pode fazer coisas totalmente
diferentes mas respeitando e vendo as
situações pelo olhar do outro e um
exemplo muito simples que eu dou com
relação a isso e que eu uso no meu dia a
dia é tenta perguntar pra ele como eu
posso contribuir de que forma eu posso
te ajudar
a maneira você tem como aquele primeiro
identificar quais são as oportunidades
segundo entender com a visão dele sobre
o ponto que você tá trabalhando está
desenvolvendo para depois poder
acrescentar de forma verdadeira e
sincera na forma de trabalhar e de
compartilhar e se você me perguntar hoje
o que você aprende você sabe tudo das
das culturas que você viveu com certeza
não eu não sei
eu voltei muito mais por um brasil com
muito mais clareza dos nossos desafios
nossas qualidades dos dados das
necessidades que a gente precisa superar
para andar pra frente como o povo e
nação e eu tenho mais vontade de saber
mais e mais sobre as culturas de
diferentes mercados que o trabalho
relacionado
hoje por exemplo essa experiência lá ela
me proporcionou com que eu tivesse um
grupo batizado picon 20 colegas e amigos
é da empresa que o trabalho da área que
o ato ea gente troca mensagens a todo
momento então tá antes de entrar aqui
cinco minutos a gente estava conversando
sobre o técnico
isso é muito interessante porque eu
consigo saber na mesma hora por exemplo
tem dia que eu acordo eu já sei de
notícias que aconteceu na austrália
porque meu amigo da índia já com 12min
então isso é muito interessante é e uma
outra experiência que eu tive é que a
empatia é fundamental na forma de se
relacionar e para ter sucesso porque
empatia isso entender o outro é entender
o que esse outro pensa quais são as
necessidades dele para que assim você
possa às vezes as necessidades elas nem
são tão diferentes da nossa oposição
a gente aprende com elas porque pode ser
aqui em rondinha na austrália nos
estados unidos na áfrica na europa em
qualquer lugar do mundo
empatia fundamental para que a gente
tenha sucesso nos negócios possa fazer
amigos e conhecer o mundo
eu acho que é isso muito obrigado